be sure to subscribe to lange focus and
click the notification button hello
everyone welcome to the lange focused
channel and my name is plaw today i want
to look at a linguistic phenomenon that
i find interesting
it's called metathesis the word
metathesis comes from the Greek word
metathesis meaning change of position or
transposition it refers to a situation
in which adjacent sounds change position
in a word for example in English we have
ask but you might have also heard ax in
some dialects you can see that the two
consonants have switched places another
example from English we have the word
asterisk which refers to this little
star looking symbol awit not that one
this one some people pronounce it as
Asterix another one the prefix intro or
intra is often pronounced like inter for
example introduced is sometimes
pronounced introduced so you can see
that the R sound and the vowel have
become reversed another one the prefix
pre or pro is often pronounced like /
for example prescription becomes
prescription we can see examples of
metathesis of side by side sound
switching positions in many different
languages in what kinds of situations
does this happen well during the
development of a language there's
sometimes a change for example the
English word bird came from Old English
Britain you can see that the R sound and
the I sound became reversed also the
English word thrilled came from the
Middle English word Theron
again the R and the vowel switched
positions second metathesis sometimes
takes place in one of two sister
languages as they develop for example
their Spanish preguntar and Portuguese
theatre green card which both mean to
ask
and there's the Czech word Pro company
and the Polish word Lukovic which both
mean kernel as in the military rank and
similarly there's sometimes a change in
certain dialects of a language but not
in others or not in the standard
language this is like we saw in the
example of ask versus ax ax is probably
the most well-known example of
metathesis and it's often thought to be
broken English or a mistake but both ask
and X have been around for over a
thousand years there
Old English asked young as well as
accion which originated through
metathesis eventually asked became the
standard pronunciation but axe is still
common in various dialect most famously
in african-american vernacular English
also known as Ebonics but it's also used
in some other dialects in the American
South as well as some dialects in
England you know that city near Europe
fourth metathesis also sometimes takes
place systematically within a language
in certain phonetic or grammatical
contexts one example comes from Hebrew
in Hebrew most words are based on roots
consisting of usually three consonants
in a specific order verbs are created by
placing the roots into a series of
templates that shape the meaning of the
root
a typical example might be like this the
root is cut over the first template is
the pile form cut off that's the
dictionary form of the verb to write
there are numerous other templates but
the key one is the hit by L template it
Cattell meaning to correspond as in by
written letters in the old days the hit
PL template often gives the route
reflexive or reciprocal meaning doing
the action together with someone else
I'll get to the metathesis in just a
second this is background information
for the Hebrew example when the first
consonant of a Hebrew root is an
alveolar or post alveolar fricative like
a Sasha or supports a' sound then the
first consonant switches positions and
comes before the tough in the hit PL
template so for example we have the root
sure ma sure which means use which in
the hit by L template becomes histah
mesh rather than hit show mesh so you
can see that the term and the show have
changed places metathesis can also
involve the transposition of entire
syllables for example in Japanese we
have the word gomen which is used to
mean I'm sorry but sometimes people say
mango which is a humorous way of saying
sorry
so metathesis is sometimes done
intentionally for humor but why else
does it take place
well it's often a momentary error
sometimes people might get confused or
nervous or they're thinking about two
overlapping concepts at the same time so
they say the wrong thing
for example maybe they intend to say
gold card but they say cold guard also
children sometimes make errors
this when they misperceived the sounds
of a word or they have trouble
reproducing them a common example is
pasghetti
instead of spaghetti but metathesis is
often what metathesis is often enduring
with shifts in words or in sound
combinations becoming a part of that
dialect or language this could happen
because certain sound combinations are
slightly more awkward to articulate than
others and people most naturally look
for the path of least resistance also it
could be that people perceive slightly
different sounds as variations of each
other for instance vowels with different
lengths or stress together with R or L
sounds so take the word pretty which is
pronounced as Purdy in some dialects and
by lots of other people trying to be
funny if you say pretty slowly
Peretti between the P and the R it
sounds like there's a slight vowel sound
there like a so maybe people came to
perceive the beginning of the word for
it and purr as clothes variations and
maybe when they say Purdy
they are perceiving a slight schwa vowel
after the are like para parody and that
slight schwa is considered a variation
of the vowel I'm speculating of course
but if you break down the sounds you can
see where people might perceive some
similarity where it's not immediately
obvious to us and there are probably
other reasons for metathesis as well
like the influence of other languages
through contact metathesis is a very
common linguistic phenomenon if you pay
attention for it if you keep your eyes
and ears open for it you'll probably see
some examples of words that are
pronounced somewhat differently from
their written form due to metathesis and
if you enjoy examining related languages
you'll likely notice some examples of
metathesis in cognate vocabulary if you
can think of any other examples of
metathesis or if you would like to ax a
question please leave them in the
comments down below be sure to follow
Lange focus on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and once again I would like to
say thank you to all of my amazing
patreon supporters especially these
people right here on the screen for
their monthly pledges thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]